llegó la hora de hablar de economía y
todas las noticias en esta materia las
tiene Daniela Blandón Daniela bienvenida
y viernes por fin viernes por fin y
también lo de la bienvenida María Clara
y empezamos este viernes con buenas
noticias relativas a la inflación en
América Latina Cómo se estima pues estas
dos últimas semanas se han venido
conociendo datos recientes de inflación
en el mundo particularmente en la región
que dan cuenta de que se ha venido
desacelerando Comenzando por Venezuela
cuya inflación anual sigue por encima
del 400% pero la mensual es tampoco
menos del 8% y ojo que está siendo
superada por Argentina que no ha
presentado datos para mayo pero que en
abril ya registraba un 8% mensual y casi
109% anual en Colombia Pues se ve como
esa parte de estos dos países el único
que se mantiene en dos dígitos mientras
que chile y Perú también Uruguay todavía
lidian con cifras altas lo vemos gráfico
México y Brasil son de los países con
inflación más bajas a la región y hay un
caso bien particular que es el de Costa
Rica con una inflación anual menor al 1%
en su tercera cifra más baja en 10 años
y es que la mayoría está con buenos
resultados pero muy lejos de las metas
de los bancos centrales Y a qué se debe
a que la mayoría de los países estén
reduciendo su inflación hay dos
situaciones particulares en la mayoría
de los casos primero que todos los
analistas endillian este resultado a que
los bancos centrales han venido subiendo
sus tasas de interés para poder frenar
el consumo de los hogares Y quitarles
presión a los precios pero también entra
en juego algo que se conoce por los
economistas como el efecto base y voy a
tratar de hacer una explicación los
precios se comparan frente al mismo mes
del año anterior entonces hagamos un
ejemplo con Colombia en Colombia el
precio de la carne hoy es mucho más caro
que antes de que iniciara la guerra en
Ucrania pero desde marzo del año pasado
comenzó a sufrir desenfrenadamente pero
como a partir de marzo de este año la
comparación se hace es frente a los
meses en los que ya hay guerra pues la
variación va a ser mucho menor pero la
carne Sigue estando cara frente a lo que
teníamos antes de la invasión
concretamente el doble del precio
tenemos hoy y ese precio no va a volver
a bajar por eso desde marzo se ha notado
un quiebre en la tendencia no solamente
en la región sino en todo el mundo y
como el quiebre es en todo el mundo los
precios altos se han visto también por
ejemplo en Europa Qué está haciendo
Francia para combatirlos Pues el
ministro de finanzas Bruno el emerja
anunció que 75 grandes actores de la
industria alimentaria se comprometieron
a bajar los precios de cientos de
productos a partir del próximo mes y
agrego que estarían en riesgo de
sanciones si incumplen esta promesa se
estima que estas compañías fabrican y
venden el 80% de lo que comen los
franceses Y es que el gobierno no se
explica como si hay gran cantidad de
productos en los que los precios
mayoristas han caído los minoristas no
han hecho lo propio la inflación en este
país está en su nivel más bajo en un año
en 6% anual pero los alimentos Sí están
subiendo a tasas de más del doble de ese
6%. cambiemos de noticia y hablemos de
la reunión entre el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden y el Primer
Ministro de Reino Unido Richie sunak
porque lograron un acuerdo histórico qué
tiene que ver o cuáles son los detalles
en materia económica pues María Clara
llegaron a un acuerdo nuevo al que le
llamaron la declaración del Atlántico
que se va a enfocar en aumentar la
cooperación bilateral principalmente en
transición energética también en
reforzar las cadenas de suministro y no
perder de vista desde luego el área de
tecnología con todo este avance de la
Inteligencia artificial pero también en
el pasado se ha hablado de un posible
tratado de libre comercio entre ambos
países y en esta ocasión se les preguntó
por qué Todavía no se ha consumado la
respuesta fue que esta atlántica es
apenas una un comienzo para alimar
asperezas que ha ocasionado la ley de
reducción de inflación de biden que en
su momento enojó a muchos países
europeos porque fortalece a las empresas
estadounidenses la subvenciona y no a
las europeas y precisamente por eso era
que lo catalogaba de histórico porque se
comienzan a limar las ásperas usted
mencionaba las energías limpias la única
noticia no tiene que ver con esto sino
que también hay un acuerdo entre dos
compañías que construyen vehículos
eléctricos de qué se trata Pues los
vehículos de General Motors tendrán
acceso a la red de cargadores eléctricos
de tesla en Estados Unidos a partir de
2024 esto tras un acuerdo anunciado por
los dos fabricantes General Motors está
adelantando millonarias inversiones para
el desarrollo de su propia red de
cargadores eléctricos pero en el entre
tanto sus vehículos van a poder utilizar
estos más de 12.000 carga rápidos que
tiene tesla y que componen la red más
extensa del país inicialmente los
vehículos eléctricos ya producidos van a
necesitar un adaptador para poder
conectarse desde a esta red de tesla Y a
partir de 2025 se va a instalar
directamente un puerto de carga de tesla
en estos autos ya Ford había firmado
hace un par de semanas un acuerdo
similar con tesla y esto convierte a la
tecnología de la firma de elon musk en
el estándar para Norteamérica Bueno
ahora quiero hacer un poco de historia
para conectarlo con algo que usted nos
tiene que decir Y es el mal trago de la
cervezas en Qatar Qué pasó ahora Bueno
vamos a recordar lo que pasó en Qatar
María Clara Recuerda usted que dos días
antes de que comenzara el torneo en
Qatar el año pasado los organizadores de
la Copa mundo retiraron esa Promesa de
permitir que los fanáticos en los
estadios comprarán cerveza con alcohol
sin que la FIFA pudiera hacer nada Eso
fue bastante polémico
Pues ahora esto dejó de una sola pieza a
Budweiser que ha patrocinado el mundial
desde 1986 pero aunque las ventas de
esta compañía cayeron en los estadios
podría decirse que la publicidad mundial
sobre la disputa impulsó la imagen de la
cervecera y ahora a nadie le quedan
dudas de quién es el que patrocina el
mundial pues mucho se preguntaban sobre
la renovación para 2026 de este contrato
ya fue confirmado por la empresa no se
dijo el valor pero sí se sabe que a
Qatar lo patrocinaron con 75 millones de
dólares
los torneos de la Copa Mundial de la
FIFA son los eventos deportivos más
populares del mundo estamos
profundamente conectados con los
aficionados y con el fútbol de todo el
mundo por lo que estamos entusiasmados
con la extensión de la relación con la
FIFA Daniela y cuál es la cifra de este
viernes
34,8 millones de dólares voy a dejar que
primero observe las siguientes imágenes
para decirle que este es el diamante de
rosa más caro de la historia la
deslumbrante joya fue subastada por Vice
en Nueva York se llama the eternal Pink
y tiene 10,57 quilates sus tonos rosados
y morados la hacen diferente a cualquier
otro diamante jamás subastado de acuerdo
con esta firma que reveló que la piedra
original fue extraída de una mina de
Botswana en 2019 divino además no divino
además si lo estuviera no sé si los
pagaría pero está muy lindo Gracias
Daniela por la información económica nos
vemos aquí en una hora